l'ouverture d'un premier magasin en Inde
et si importantes pour le géant
américain que Tim Cook le grand patron
d'Apple accueille lui-même les clients
ils sont venus d'un peu partout dans le
pays pour faire la file celui-ci a pris
l'avion en pleine nuit pour pouvoir être
sur place
de l'Inde pays le plus peuplé de la
planète et deuxième plus grand marché de
la téléphonie mobile comme plusieurs
autres entreprises désireuses de réduire
leur dépendance à la chaîne
d'approvisionnement chinoise fragilisée
par la pandémie et les tensions avec les
États-Unis Apple compte aussi déplacer
une partie de sa production de la Chine
vers l'Inde le géant américain travaille
de concert avec les sociétés taïwanaises
Foxconn et westron et compte produire le
quart de tous ces iPhone en Inde d'ici
deux ans
c'est le résultat de 7 ans d'efforts et
d'incitatifs fiscaux offert dans le
cadre de la politique make in India
aussi profité des récentes rencontres du
G20 dans le pays pour faire avancer ses
ambitions aux technologiques comme ici à
Bangalore dans le sud l'un veut devenir
un des joueurs importants du marché du
véhicule électrique et de ses
composantes
[Musique]
lancement à grande déploiement de la
première moto électrique indienne
capable d'atteindre 150 km/h et
possédant une autonomie de 300
kilomètres
de quoi générer de l'intérêt pour le
produit dans 190 pays les employés ont
travaillé dans des entreprises
étrangères des domaines de l'aérospatial
des hautes technologies et de
l'automobile avant de former cette
compagnie indienne aux ambitions
mondiales
le plus grand salon asiatique des
véhicules électriques avaient lieu à
Bangalore la semaine dernière signe de
la croissance fulgurante du marché
indien
China
même cette entreprise chinoise du
domaine de la connectivité sont à
déplacer une partie de sa production
plusieurs analystes voient des
similarités entre l'Inde d'aujourd'hui
et le Japon ou la Corée du Sud des
années 80 et 90 des pays qui
s'apprêtaient alors à exporter leurs
produits ou reste de la planète ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada Bengalore
en Inde